let's bring in David priest he's the
publisher and Chief Operating Officer at
the National Security website law fair
he's also a Former Intelligence officer
at the CIA David thanks for being here
you bet how do you see this playing out
right now with what Putin is saying and
doing yeah it's really interesting to
watch how this shift has happened with
the escalation that Putin is now
involved in he thinks that he's going to
even now somehow get the ukrainians to
submit if I fire a few more missiles at
a few more civilian centers that'll
knock out their will to fight and that's
not what we've seen I imagine that my
former colleagues at CIA are presenting
intelligence to the president and others
in the government saying the Ukrainian
will to fight is strong and every time
the Russians have escalated when they've
gone after civilian targets it actually
increases the ukrainian's will to fight
and it makes them want to see this thing
through to the end even if it involves
significant loss of life in the future
even if there are a lot of people in the
U.S who would like the ukrainians to get
to the table eventually
uh to negotiate something that gets us
away from this very tense moment yeah
really hard to go to the negotiating
table if you're zielinski right now
because the Russians have not only
brutalized your people but they're still
holding on to significant amounts of
Ukrainian territory and that's not a
good time to go to the negotiating table
hence we see the very strong
counter-offensive of the last several
weeks the ukrainians are moving to a
position where Putin's going to have
some tough choices to make about what is
he actually going to do to escalate if
at all or is he going to pull out of
some of these areas to enable some face
saving measure on his own part frankly
I'm not seeing it yet Putin seems to be
escalating the rhetoric just the same
way as generals are escalating the
battlefield activity but that is what
we're looking for I want to turn to
another aspect of Russia and this deals
with Russia interference in October days
before the 2020 election you signed on
to this open letter that was published
by Politico it said we write to say that
the arrival on the U.S political scene
of emails purportedly belonging to Vice
President Biden's son Hunter much of it
related to his time serving on the board
of the Ukrainian gas company barisma has
all the classic earmarks of a Russian
information operation why did you sign
on to that yeah because of what it says
it has all the classic earmarks of one
of these operations you'll note
elsewhere in the letter if you read it
that it also says we don't know if this
is a Russian operation at all that has
been dramatically changed in the
retelling of the story but the letter is
merely pointing out that this is the
kind of thing that Time After Time After
Time people who study Russian
disinformation Intelligence Officers who
look at Russian tactics over the long
period of time this is the kind of thing
they like to amplify to sow Discord
within Target countries sometimes that
Target country is the United States
right most often in the Cold War it was
Europe but the fact is the tactic is an
old one a tried and true one and it's
been successful in this case it was not
true it was not true in fact the New
York Times found that these are
authenticated The Washington Post writes
thousands of emails purportedly from the
laptop computer of Hunter Biden are
authentic Communications that can be
verified through cryptographic
signatures from Google and other
technology companies say two Security
Experts who examine the data New York
Post who did the story first says holy
cow here are these other verifications
and then in the debate right before the
election uh now President Biden used it
take a listen
Reckless absolutely Reckless Putin heard
this our allies and Friends heard this
this is true
from Hell president Trump nobody talking
about race right now and I do want to
stay on the issue of race president
Trump just respond to that please
because look very cool there are 50
former National Intelligence folks who
said that what this he's accusing me of
is a Russian plan you mean the laptop is
now another Russia Russia Russia hoax
that's exactly what this is exactly what
this is where he's so understanding how
you characterize it but he characterized
it differently and used it in the debate
just days before an election yeah I'll
let President Biden speak for himself
he's capable of doing that what I'll do
is say that it has all the classic ear
marks of a Russian campaign in the way
it was disseminated and propagated
through media do you regret signing on
to the letter oh absolutely not because
those words are still true it has all
the classic earmarks oh absolutely not
no this is no it wasn't true no had the
classic year marks but it wasn't true
what is not true that it was Russian
disinformation that's not what we said
in the letter read the actual letter and
we said we do not know if this is
Russian disinformation it has all the
classic earmarks of a Russian
information operation exactly the
difference between an information you're
talking about the disinformation
campaign it's not my fault if people
don't look up definition I know but you
the purpose of the letter is to have an
effect and the Nuance that you're
talking about here never made it to
candidate Biden because he said it
plainly on a debate stage that obviously
affected the dynamic don't you think I
would absolutely love for all news media
to show Nuance on all these issues
instead of racing to sound bites and in
this case some news media race to sound
bites that's not helpful for the
American people and I really wish that
people helpful for the American people
well instead of quoting one sentence
from it if people actually read maybe an
entire paragraph it shows that we don't
know if it's Russian affected anything I
don't know if it affected anything but
we don't analyze American political
environments I'm trying to what we're
trying to do is point out that this has
all the classic earmarks of a Russian
information campaign not to say it's
Russian disinformation but to say that
the propagation through American Media
and international media has all the
classic earmarks of a Russian
information campaign because we've seen
it over and over and over again they
love to sow these kind of Divisions and
exacerbate them that's not American
that's Russian I got you yeah but it
ended up being a Biden information
campaign because he used it in the
campaign and in that debate I Encore you
to ask him about that and I will thank
you very much do you bet for the time